they are loaded Oh - pitch curveball a shot there down into the corner it goes Fowler is in right behind him his Edmond he will score and in the second base with a 2 RBI double Marcell Ozuna 3 Cardinals you wonder how long they will stick with Melanson probably got one more batter you would think bases are loaded for long and a curve ball is hit down the line fair ball Hamlin's going to get past Freeman down into the corner and this is going to bring in two more runs two shots just inside the bags one inside third the other inside first delivered a lot of traffic tonight and it's seven to five it's a two-run game with one swing of the bat 2 & 2 the count 7 6 save Lewis Freeman's got him knocking at the door here comes a one-two from Martinez Markakis takes a called strike three and the ball game is over Martinez picks up the win some extreme bending but he doesn't break and the Cardinals win a road game in Game one